There's a lot of
anxiety in the country.
And as a result, we're
not hearing each other.
We're not talking to each other.
We stick with like-minded
people and have lost our ability
to appreciate that someone's
life experience may
be very different than yours.
What I tried to do with this
series is to not judge people,
but to encourage an
open, honest dialogue,
actually listen to each
other, be critical thinkers,
and be open minded.
These are really
complicated topics
to unpack, white anxiety, gender
inequality, tech addiction.
I don't think this series is
going to change the world,
but I'm hoping it
will help people
see a different perspective.
ANNOUNCER: "America Inside
Out," with Katie Couric,
Wednesday, April 11th at
10:00 on National Geographic.